Em ensaios clínicos, uma dose específica
de ácido alfalipoico mostrou resultados
que muita gente não espera de um
antioxidante. Estudo publicado no
Diabetes Care em 2011, o famoso Nan One
acompanhou 460 pacientes diabéticos por
4 anos, usando 600 mg diários, encontrou
melhora significativa em déficit
neurológico. Mas o que pouca gente sabe
é que esse composto não começou como
suplemento de prateleira. Ele foi usado
clinicamente na Europa no século passado
em pacientes com doenças hepáticas
graves, incluindo intoxicação por
cogumelos venenosas e cirrose. Hoje eu
vou te mostrar o que que a ciência
moderna descobriu sobre essa dose de 600
mg, quando ela faz sentido e porque o
ácido afalipôico não é um simples detox,
mas um verdadeiro modulador metabólico.
Antes de continuar, eu preciso
contextualizar porque esse composto
merece atenção. Com avanço da idade,
três processos se aceleram
silenciosamente no corpo. O estresse
oxidativo aumenta, a inflamação
metabólica se instala e o fígado começa
a acumular gordura. Essas alterações
contribuem para a resistência à
insulina, esteatose hepática e piora
progressiva da função metabólica. E aqui
está o problema. Muitas vezes isso
acontece antes de aparecer qualquer
alteração nos exames de rotina. Você
pode estar com glicemia de jejum normal
e já ter resistência insulínica
instalada. O ácido alfalipôico ou ala é
uma molécula que seu corpo produz
naturalmente nas mitocôndrias. Ele
funciona como cofator essencial para
várias enzimas do metabolismo
energético. Mas aqui está um
diferencial. Ele é um dos poucos
antioxidantes que funciona tanto em meio
acoso quanto em meio lipídico, ou seja,
gorduroso. Isso significa que ele
consegue atuar em praticamente todos os
compartimentos celulares, algo que a
vitamina C sozinha não consegue fazer.
Vamos aos estudos. No ensaio clínico
Sydney 2, publicado no dia Biriscare em
2006, testou doses orais de 600, 100 mg
por dia em 180 pacientes diabéticos com
neuropatia periférica. Depois de 5
semanas, todas as doses melhoraram os
sintomas, mas a conclusão foi clara. 600
mg uma vez ao dia oferece a melhor
relação risco benefício. Doses maiores
não trouxeram benefício adicional
significativo e aumentaram os efeitos
colaterais gastrointestinais.
Mais recentemente, em 2024, um ensaio
clínico duplo cego com 50 pacientes com
doença hepática gordurosa nãoólica, a
famosa esteatose mostrou que 600 mg de
ácido alfalipôico combinado com vitamina
E por 12 semanas reduziu
significativamente o índice
que é o marcador de resistência à
insulina, além de diminuir os níveis de
insulina em jejum. Outro estudo de 2023
com 46 pacientesanos com síndrome
metabólica mostrou que 600 mg de ala por
12 semanas reduziu os triglicerídeos em
37 pontos em média enquanto o grupo
placebo aumentou seis pontos. O
colesterol total também melhorou. Agora,
deixe de contar a história que quase
ninguém conhece. Muito antes de virar
suplemento de prateleira, o
astrofalipoico foi estudado e utilizado
na Alemanha em outros países europeus
como agente terapêutico em doenças
hepáticas. Em 1979, o New England
Journal of Medicine publicou um relato
sobre o uso de asto tióctico, que é
outro nome para o ala, no tratamento de
intoxicação por cogumelo amanita
faloides, aquele cogumelo mortal que
destrói o fígado. O racional era
simples. O ala tem capacidade de
regenerar antioxidantes endógenos como a
gluta melhorar o metabolismo hepático e
reduzir danos oxidativos. Mas como
exatamente o ala funciona no seu corpo?
Primeiro ele regenera outros
antioxidantes. Quando a vitamina C ou a
vitamina E são gastas neutralizando
radicais livres, o ala consegue
reciclá-las de volta afativa. Segundo,
ele aumenta os níveis de gluta
intracelular, que é o antioxidante
mestre do seu corpo. Terceiro, ele
melhora a captação de glicose pelas
células através da ativação do PI3K HT.
o mesmo mecanismo que a insulina usa.
Por isso, alguns pesquisadores chamam
ala de insulino mimético. Agora, vem uma
dúvida comum. Qual que a diferença entre
o ala comum e o r ala? Essa é uma
pergunta importante. O ácido alfalipoico
tem duas formas, o r ala, que é a forma
natural produzida pelo seu corpo, e o s
ala, que é uma forma sintética. Ou
suplementos comuns contêm uma mistura de
50 a 50 dessas duas formas chamado de
mistura racêmica. Estudos de
farmacocinética mostram que o Rala tem
biodisponibilidade cerca de 40 a 50%
maior que o S ala. Então, por que que
não só usa o R ala? Aqui tá o paradoxo
interessante. O Rala puro é instável,
ele tende a se polimerizar, ou seja, as
moléculas se grudam uma nas outras, o
que reduz drasticamente a absorção.
Então, ironicamente, a presença do SA lá
na mistura racêmica impede essa
polimerização e melhora a estabilidade.
Por isso, em muitos casos, a mistura
racêmica comum pode ter absorção igual
ou até melhor que formulações baratas de
r ala puro. A exceção são as formas
estabilizadas de rala, como o caso na
rala, que é o R lipoato de sódio que
consegue oferecer absorção superior. Na
prática, se você está começando, a forma
racêmica comum de 600 mg funciona bem e
tem um respaldo na maioria dos estudos
clínicos. Se quiser otimizar, pode
buscar Rala estabilizado, mas aí a dose
seria menor, em torno de 150 a 300 mg,
justamente pela maior
biodisponibilidade.
Sobre segurança, o perfil é muito bom.
Os estudos de longo prazo, incluindo o
Natã 1 de 4 anos, não encontraram
toxicidade hepática. Os efeitos
colaterais mais comuns são
gastrointestinais leves, como náusea,
que geralmente melhoram tomando junto
com o alimento. Uma observação
importante, o ala, ele pode
potencializar o efeito de medicamentos
para diabetes. Então, se você usa
insulina ou hipoglicementos orais,
converse com seu médico sobre ajuste de
dose. Para quem o ácido alfalipoico faz
mais sentido? Então, baseado na
literatura, três grupos se beneficiam
mais: pessoas com resistência à insulina
ou pré-diabetes, pessoas com esteatose
hepática não alcoólica e diabéticos com
neuropatia periférica. A dose 600 mg uma
vez ao dia, preferencialmente em jejum
ou 30 minutos antes de uma refeição, é o
que os estudos utilizaram com sucesso.
Então, um erro comum que eu vejo na
prática é a pessoa tomar aa junto com
refeições ricas em carboidratos. achando
que vai bloquear a absorção de açúcar.
Não funciona assim. Ola melhora a
sensibilidade insulínica ao longo do
tempo. Não é um bloqueador agudo. Outro
erro é usar doses muito baixas, tipo 100
ou 200 mg, esperando os mesmos
resultados dos estudos. A literatura é
consistente. Os benefícios metabólicos e
neurológicos aparecem com 600 mg. E uma
dica prática, se você sentir queimação
estomacal, experimente tomar um copo
cheio de água ou junto com uma pequena
quantidade de proteína. Bem, aqui no
YouTube eu preciso simplificar, omitir
protocolos mais específicos sobre o
ácido afalipoico, por exemplo, eu não
posso falar detalhadamente como combinam
com outros compostos e patoprotetores ou
as dosagens que eu uso em caso de terose
mais avançada. Aqui, porém, na
comunidade fechada, eu compartilho tudo
sem filtro, protocolos exatos da
clínica, incluindo a combinação de aula
com cilimarina, beberina e os cofatores
que potencializam o efeito fornecedores
confiáveis, interpretação avançada de
exames hepáticos, lives semanais e PDF
com 47 protocolos, grupo no WhatsApp,
clique em seja membro. E no nível dois,
a cada duas semanas, fazemos imersões de
2 horas desse artigos científicos, como
os estudos Sidney e Nathan que eu
mencionei hoje, debatendo controvérsia
sobre formas de ala e biodisponibilidade
e os bastidores da ciência. Seu nome
será mencionado nos vídeos como
agradecimento. É o ciclo interno de quem
quer ir além. E já que estamos falando
de metabolismo hepático e resistência
insulina, você precisa entender como a
Beberina atua nesses mesmos mecanismos.
Assista meu vídeo sobre biberina versus
metiformina que vai complementar
perfeitamente o que você aprendeu hoje.
Agradecimentos especiais aos nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube.
Começando pelos novos membros que
entraram recentemente, Walter Salgado,
Luciano Silvo Polinelli, Luciano Elias,
Carlos Roveri, Odonor Pinheiro, Cíntia
de Assis Oliveira, Jorge Cabral e
Fernando Machado. Sejam muito
bem-vindos. Agradeço também aos membros
que fizeram upgrade por os estudos
avançados. Irma Carol e Ana Medicina,
Adriane, Dra. Ana Paulo Rodriges, José
Fortunato Murtinho, Sou Jucioli,
Cristina Carol, Romana Moraril, Estela
Mares, Eloterapias Integrativas e Saúde,
Luís Anselmo Neves, obrigado pela
confiança em elevar o nível de
participação. Um abraço especial aos
membros que retornaram à comunidade,
Alex Caldas, Marcelo Pimentel e Cláudia
Leitão. Que bom ter vocês de volta.
Quero fazer um reconhecimento especial
aos membros mais fiéis. Estela Mares com
incríveis 57 meses de fidelidade. Dr.
Ana Paulo Rodrigues com 45 meses de
participação. Marcelo Pimentel com 24
meses e eloterapias integrativas com 10
meses de história conosco. A todos vocês
eu agradeço de coração pelo apoio
prestado. Vocês fazem a diferença nessa
comunidade.